cloud computing is becoming more
prominent among tech companies and
organizations making this skill in
demand in the sector cloud-based
solutions are proven to be a boon for
company management around the world
because they provide convenience at an
inexpensive price
this means that if you want to work in
technology
a job dealing with cloud-based systems
could be a great fit
hey everyone i'm sharmly and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on how to become a cloud engineer
according to market and markets the
global cloud computing industry was
valued at
371.4 billion usd in 2020
it has been predicted that cloud
engineer will be among the top 10 in
demand id jobs in 2021
therefore in this video we will come
across some of the very important
aspects needed to become a cloud
engineer
like first of all we will understand
what is cloud computing
then we will understand who is a cloud
engineer
after that we will look into the
technical skills needed to become a
cloud engineer
after that we will understand what are
the roles and responsibilities of a
cloud engineer
then we will have a look into the road
map of becoming a cloud engineer
and what is the average salary of a
cloud engineer in both the usa and in
india
and at last we will look at the
companies hiring cloud engineers
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
the first thing we will come across is
what is cloud computing
cloud computing is the distribution of
computing services via the internet
or the cloud
including servers storage databases
networking software analytics and
intelligence to provide faster
innovation more flexible resources and
economies of scale
you usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
cost run your infrastructure more
efficiently and scale as your business
grows
that brings us to who is a cloud
engineer
cloud engineers are the i.t experts in
charge of accessing an organization's
technology infrastructure and
transferring operations and procedures
to a cloud-based architecture
they assist with the migration of
critical corporate applications and
processes to private public and hybrid
cloud com environments
a cloud engineer's job is to access a
company's id infrastructure and migrate
certain processes and operations to the
cloud
public private and hybrid cloud
computing systems are among these
functions and operations
now that we know who a cloud engineer is
let's have a look at the skills required
to become one
cloud engineers must have a diverse set
of technical talents that they will use
in a variety of positions
several key skill sets that cloud
engineers need to be successful include
the ability to program and code
cloud-based applications and processes
the ability to troubleshoot technical
challenges through problem solving
the ability to plan and design software
and cloud applications using critical
and creative thinking
should also include data analysis skills
and should be able to strategically plan
and to fulfill projects using technical
resources
now let's have a look at the roles and
responsibilities of cloud engineer
there are three types of cloud engineers
in particular in a small business one
individual may be in charge of all three
roles
cloud
cloud software engineer and cloud
security engineer
cloud architect and organizations cloud
computing strategy include application
design management and monitoring is
overseen by a cloud architect
cloud architects connect various aspects
of cloud computing including data and
networks with tools and services
cloud software engineer a cloud software
engineer creates software for cloud
computing systems and is in charge of
managing their development and
maintenance
cloud security engineer
control based technologies and
procedures that enable regulatory
compliance regulations are included in
security
when dealing with the cloud the major
purpose is to protect information data
data applications and the infrastructure
now let's focus on the roadmap to become
a cloud engineer
cloud engineers generally begin their
careers with a four year degree in
computer technology
and the steps below defined fundamental
part to becoming a cloud engineer
obtain a bachelor's degree
in software and systems infrastructure
computing or other technical areas
your bachelor's degree program should
emphasize software and system
infrastructure computing and other
technical courses
a bachelor's degree in a computer or
technology related field will also
qualify you for advanced degrees if you
choose to pursue them
learn programming languages python c
plus plus java and ruby for example are
great options to start with
aside from programming languages you'll
want to brush up on your knowledge and
skills with some of the most popular
cloud services including aws hadoop and
azure
it's important that you gain experience
in cloud computing why internships and
open source projects
this will help you build a portfolio of
work that you can use to demonstrate
your competence in future job interviews
and it will also teach you vital skills
that you'll need to need on job
consider a master's degree
to enhance your cloud computing
abilities while also advancing your
career
because of their higher level of
education cloud engineers with a
master's degree in a tech subject may
have additional career prospects a
master's degree in software engineering
or system engineering for example will
help you develop more of these technical
abilities and expertise advancing your
career
get cloud computing certification
to demonstrate your understanding and
skill level in cloud engineering you can
also check out our official website for
cloud computing certification
it will help you enhance your knowledge
in this particular field
now that we know everything about cloud
computing and how to become a cloud
engineer
let's have a quick look at the average
salary of a cloud engineer in india and
in the usa
in india the average salary of a cloud
engineer is rupees
12 lakh 41 000 per annum
and in the usa the average salary of a
cloud engineer is
128
837
per annum
now cloud engineers may earn a
substantial income with a national
average salary but it can vary though
depending on your location and how many
years you have been in the field for
example a cloud engineer with a master's
degree and several years of experience
may make more than a new graduate with a
four-year degree who's just starting out
in their career
now let's dive down and explore the
companies hiring cloud engineers
cloud computing is gradually
establishing itself as the industry
standard for data storage and
administration by 2022 according to ivc
over a million cloud computing jobs
would be generated in india
amazon ibm vipro infosys oracle cisco
these are the few top companies were
some of the top recruiters in this field
so this is all about how to become a
cloud engineer we have almost reached
the end of this video if i missed
anything important do let me know in the
comments section
i hope you enjoyed this video on how to
become a cloud engineer and learn
something new from it
if you like this video then please do
hit the like button thanks for watching
this video and stay tuned for more
updates and videos from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here